[Applause]
happy Thursday everybody so sometimes
the universe reminds you that for every
action there's an equal and opposite
reaction Like Jesse waters getting the
800 p.m. hour after being diagnosed with
micr
penis did we say that yes here's
it here's another example the wildly
popular comedian named Shane Gillis if
you've never heard of him here's a taste
ton night the United States killed the
leader of Isis Trump comes out of the
Situation Room at like midnight he walks
up in front of the entire world at
midnight and just goes Abu bagar Al bag
daddy is dead he died like a dog in
front of the whole world
Abu we could hear him crying I said Abu
don't cry AB let me tell you something
Abu cried he cried quite a bit I
wouldn't have
cried
Cy baby back Daddy that's what we were
all
calling he's funny and he does Trump
better than Alec Baldwin plus plus he
hasn't shot
anyone yet but what's special about
Gillis is that he beat canel culture in
2019 he was hired as a cast member on
Saturday Night Live but was fired before
he ever appeared on the show After
People dug up old clips in which he made
jokes about Asians now if you've seen
SNL in the past few years you might even
say he got lucky you know he's like the
guy who causes a Ruckus at the gate so
he's banned from boarding the plane and
then that flight
crashes SNL is like that crashing plane
only not as
funny wow thank
you really paints a I got some Applause
from a sick
person but it's no surprise they fired
him before he set foot on stage he was
too dangerous for elitist snobs who
think anything Trump or republican is an
automatic punchline he also didn't tick
any boxes that they liked and the ones
he did white and male were like a French
kiss from your
grandmother the last thing they wanted
but the fact is they needed him more
than he needed them because since then
he's become a huge success enter Bud
Light you remember them right last year
they briefly partnered with trans
influencer Dylan Mulaney which alienated
their customer base resulting in
boycotts that cost billions thank God we
never covered that it started April 1st
after Mulaney AKA peee herim anheiser
bush has lost 5 billion with a b as in
beup sales are plummeting faster than
Hunter Biden's pants in a porno theater
ban influenced Bud's customers to switch
to St paully girl so they won't have to
wonder what's under the skirts after all
we prefer our beer nuts to be in a bowl
it's the first first time Dylan's
complaining about the Scandal more proof
that he's not a woman how do you like
them Adams
apples so thanks to their woke
desperation anheiser Bush's stock
dropped faster than Chris Christie in a
hot air balloon so did they learn their
lesson it appears so because guess who
budl is partnering it with now Shane
Gillis yes it appears public humiliation
works because budlight severed ties with
Mulaney faster than Megan Markle severed
Prince Harry's
balls on the spectrum of regular dudess
Gillis is about as far away as you can
get from Mulaney without a beerbelly
transplant and so Bud announced on
Instagram welcome to the team Shane
Gillis excited to be part of your 2024
tour and you got to admit that's a much
better slogan than 203s Bud the king of
beers for Queens with
penises so why now well maybe they tuned
into Joe
Rogan I feel like you should be the new
spokesperson you can turn this around
they better hurry up and give me some
money or I'm going to start drinking
cers
[Applause]
light who knew it was that easy I should
try that hey Preparation H you better
give me some money or I'm going to
switch to
tux wait there's a wait I'm sorry
no you you don't know tux no I don't
apparently and you haven't
lived I haven't lived so now an eer Bush
clearly wants to move on and start
selling beer again they learned two key
rules of marketing don't insult your
core customers and when choosing a
spokeswoman beer drinking Bros want
girls in bikinis not girls who ask for a
reacharound oh my God and with Gillis
what better spokesman than a guy who
actually looks like he uses the product
a lot that's how companies laugh all the
way to the bank and not the unemployment
line moan acted like he'd never seen a
beer before the ad was shot but Gillis
looks like he spoons with a 30 pack
every
night it's imperative find a
spokesperson who seems like they use the
product or hell even looks like the
product if I were Mattel I'd hire this
lady to sell He-Man
dolls one of my childhood favorite I'm
sorry
Alisa Alisa hiners Shide remember that's
the executive who brought on mulany once
complained that bud had used too much
fratty humor in the past and guess who
handed me my Quarter Pounder through the
drive-through window yesterday Al Lisa
hiners
Shide I kid McDonald's is for fratty
jerks too but you know who likes fratty
humor beer drinkers people who enjoy
drinking beer your customers you're not
selling to trans influencers there's
only one and you used them in the ad so
Bud's doing the right thing and good for
them maybe our leaders will learn the
same lesson if you insult the people who
made you they can unmake you too at
least now they have a spokesman emphasis
on man who will make us laugh on purpose
and not cuz he looks like Audrey
heurn if anything this opens the door
for other troubled Brands to do the same
because you know maybe dudes are the
answer maybe Disney should hire Larry
the Cable Guy hell Ben and Jerry's
should hire Tyrus he could have his own
flavor Kick-Ass
crunch I might try that yeah and
Victoria's Secret you know maybe it's
time oh my
God I'll get in shape so good on Bud
Light for rediscovering its core values
while SNL limps along like a solar
powered Prius first bud got the UFC then
pton Manning and now Gillis if they got
any fraer they'd sponsor a fart lighting
contest let's welcome tonight's
guest the Energizer Bunny sends her hate
mail host of the fox True Crime podcast
Emily
capano as a former judge this comedian's
Act is always out of order actor and
comedian Vince
August she saw her shadow this morning
which means six more weeks of not eating
New York Times bestselling author and
contributor Captain you eat more than I
do and his shirt size has more X's than
Taylor New York Times bestselling author
comedian and former NWA world champion
PIR Emily as we're walking on you asked
me would I ever take a job SP uh with B
for Bud Light I would say hell yes
because you know they're paying that's
what I was asking you is how much would
you do it for and then you were like
free but I feel like the question I
never said free you said you would do it
I would do it for a lot of money how
much it had to be seven figures and the
decibal point has to be over the other
side of the yes same yeah I would do it
for like $100,000 is this a good move
you think yes and I think what's
interesting that we're watching in real
time and you sort of laid it out is them
they're being actually pretty ballsy
with the apology move so they're
unabashedly hiring the exact opposite
the exact an antithesis of what they
pledged that they weren't about right
right and you look at the numbers so
apparently they paid Dylan malaney
$226,000 and then they lost almost $30
billion do you remember in 2016 when
pton Manny he just mentioned Budweiser
there's sort of a HBL about it because
he me mentioned it and they argued at
the time that just him talking about it
was worth 13.9 m million dollars in
advertising and the point was they never
paid him so now though I'll bet you they
are paying Payton and Shane Gillis
millions and millions and millions and
millions and they're having to do it in
the long game they're basically saying
you know what worth it because all of
these numbers pale in comparison to $30
billion did you hear that
tux huh I'll make you a millionaire
stick with me kid I shouldn't be doing
that about tux Vin it is kind of funny
though their initial thing was to bash
Frat Boys and then they've got like the
the the the hood ornament of he's not
he's better than frat humor I shouldn't
say that he's a extremely funny
hilarious guy how did you not do a Dylan
Mulaney and Tux
joke you know somewhere in there that
would occurred to me my problem was
never with Dylan mulvania it was with
Alicia Jingleheimer Schmid whatever her
name is um because it was we're not that
anymore we're this and and why do you
have to be one or the other yeah I mean
you know you the people that always
trying to be inclusive are the ones that
separate us in groups and the group that
you're targeting is alcoholics and those
span everybody yes you should just say
listen this beer is so good you're going
to drink so much of it you're going to
get so drunk you're not going to know if
you're going home with chain Gillis or
Dylan
mulany but tomorrow morning you're going
to have a good story either way like
that's
totally cat why aren't we approached to
be spokes people you know we were there
first when it came to cancel culture we
think Bud should be underwriting this
show and we love money and we do
drink yeah I also think that with Bud
Light it wasn't I think a lot of people
feel how you feel they were mad about
not Dylan mulany but about saying
purposely they're trying to get rid of
their most popular consumers but I also
think there was another piece to it
which just drinking a Bud Light is an
invitation for any anyone in the bar to
come up and talk to you about it yes
that's true a lot of people just didn't
want that like if you're drinking that
then someone anybody's going to be like
like and and if you're drinking a Bud
Light there's only two reasons you're
drinking it either you drank a lot of
booze already you're trying to slow it
down mhm or you have a lot of drinking
booze to do and you're trying to take it
slow yeah you're managing your drinking
yeah in none of those situations do you
want any additional externality is
coming at you yes so I think that
although obviously Shane Gillis I think
represents the brand and what it really
always has been if you still run the
risk of the guy like like people might
still not want to take that risk yeah
you almost have to wait till those
people
die everyone who's been alive for that
commercial needs to die first exactly
they need to go after uh beer drinkers
who aren't born yet children Tyrus good
move on Bud's part not good enough yeah
not good enough hate to kill the little
party I have a problem with Dylan
Mulaney I had a problem with somebody
doing Woman face making fun of spitting
in the face of women uh had nothing to
do with him being in trans I did the
other thing that bud is not yes they're
shelling out money trying to get guys
back on the team but they have laid off
what 20% of their labor force they're
the the people who live by the Arenas
and baseball stadiums across the country
have all been laid off just last week
they were laying people off so yeah
you're going to put a little bit of
money in in one comedian's pocket and
that's great but how about hiring back
the people that you laid off like that
instead of admitting you're wrong so I
think it's great and I can I can speak
on it because I drank Bud Light yeah it
was the best beer to go with on
barbecuing yeah you know and how many do
you have to drink Tyrus that was the
beautiful thing for me to get where I
need to go with Bud Light I need at
least
24 so I always keep 12 yeah cuz
everything in my house I only get half
enjoyment so I just get kind of there
but uh and and I was Die Hard Bud Light
because I even had the Bud Light orange
loved it thought it was great it was a
beer I drank in college and I don't
change much I dressed the same since I
was 13 you're not going to get the
commercial you understand that kiss my
ass I don't need I got some money but I
my Integrity is more than that I
wouldn't take a dime from them right now
and I I drank it my entire life because
the apolog is not good enough cuz we
haven't seen it come out and say we were
wrong for allowing a person in Woman
face to degre great women and this will
not happen again try that they always do
the apology like we're sorry for sorry
for what what exact like I tell my kids
what are you exactly sorry for you spit
in the face of middle class of America
you made fun of women because you didn't
think anyone matter and you had some
dumbass talking about everyone was
stupid you lost a bunch of money good
Americans lost jobs you're giving a
little bit here and there but who's
going to step up and say this ain't
going to happen again and here's how and
by the way the employees who've worked
for us for decades and even Generations
we're going to get it back in this is
house so maybe we don't get a bunch of
sponsors who get money maybe that money
goes back to the workers because that's
who got hurt in this hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else